what is going on there reject nation
greg here today thank you so much for
clicking on this video so this is the
second movie that i easily get the most
crap for never having seen i'm a 90s kid
never saw this film never i tell people
i've never seen it it's again the same
thing i have with forrest gump was i
can't believe you have not seen the
shawshank redemption it's so good yeah
figured why not do a movie reaction i'm
actually shooting this like midnight
right now on whatever random day this i
don't remember what day today is my
schedule's been off ever since stranger
things but we are here and i'm excited
to watch it thank you so much for
clicking if you can leave a like that
would be so appreciated also subscribe
and click that notification bell and as
per usual full length reaction watch
alongs where you sync up with your own
copy i'm watching this off hbo max
is over at our patreon page for super
sexy rejects cover a whole bunch of
shows over there as well we're at the
same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch long's
included any movie or show that we cover
here the full-length watch along is
available over at our patreon page thank
you to the prepper team for helping me
edit down these highlights
i know it takes place in a prison that's
about all i know
let's see what's going on in this film
[Music]
what happened after you argued with your
wife
she packed a bag to go and stay with mr
quinton
glenn quentin
the golf pro at the snowden hills
country club the man you had recently
discovered was your wife's lover david
prova from the sopranos is in this drove
to his house to confront them they
weren't home so i
parked in the turnout and
waited
with one intention
i'm not sure
i was confused uh drunk
well i hope you murdered her well where
i get hazy is where the cleaning woman
shows up the following morning and finds
your wife in bed with her lover riddled
with 38-caliber bullets
how does that strike you as a fantastic
coincidence mr defrayner is it just me
you're coming across a little guilty
dude yet you still maintain that you
threw your gun into the river before the
murders took place it's the truth
since i am innocent of this crime sir i
find it decidedly inconvenient that the
gun was never found
that's a very good response we have the
accused at the scene of the crime we
have footprints tire tracks we have
bullets screwing on the ground which
bear his fingerprints
a broken bourbon bottle likewise with
fingerprints and most of all roger
deacon's cinematography
by the power vested in me by the state
of maine
i hereby order you to serve two life
sentences back to back
it's weird tim robbins and morgan
freeman look dh to me so you see how
they look now we see by your file you
have served 20 years of a life sentence
yes sir you feel you've been
rehabilitated
oh yes sir
no longer danger to society
that's god's honest truth
oh
i don't know why i'm already rooting for
him let's get out of here
[Music]
wow this looks like one hell of a prison
i would love to visit this location if
it's not still an active person
[Music]
[Applause]
new blood
holy [ __ ] is that clancy brown
everyone's so de-aged in this movie
looked like a stiff breeze would blow
him over
that was my first impression of the man
what do you say
a tall drink of water with a silver
spoon up his ass
never had
10 cigarettes that's a rich bet this
looks like a fun prison
[Music]
it's interesting how it can successfully
shift perspective between morgan
freeman's character and tim robbins so
effortlessly effortlessly i'm mr norden
the warden
you are convicted
felons that's why they've sent you to me
rule number one
no blasphemy god damn it
the first night's the toughest
no doubt about it
somebody always breaks down grind
it's as good a thing to bet on as any i
guess
i had my money on andy dufresne
god prison must really suck i don't
belong here we have a winner
and it's fat ass by a nose
fist
fist
fish
good old william sadler man
you don't understand i'm not supposed to
be here open that
oh my god
if i hear so much as a mouse fart in
here the rest of the night
i swear by god and sonny jesus you will
all visit the infirmary every last
[ __ ] in here
i hope a mouse doesn't fart goddamn i
never want to meet clancy brown
but god damn do i respect him his first
night in the joint and dufresne cost me
two packs of cigarettes
he never made a sound
that's a damn good white boy
there's so much character to this prison
like just the environment and the
structure
oh my god are you going to eat that
i
hadn't planned on it
do you mind
uh
that's nice and ripe
what the [ __ ]
oh okay all right
jake says thank you i hope that bird
doesn't die fine morning in it you know
why it's a fine morning don't you come
on set them down i want them all lined
up here just like a pretty little chorus
line
damn red looks pissed
i was just wondering if anyone knew his
name
doesn't [ __ ] matter what his name was
he's dead
i tell you you feel a little bad about
it don't you
wife killing banker
why'd you do it
i didn't since you asked
you gonna fit right in
or maybe you'd like to sink your toe
into somebody's skull
no sir
i have no enemies here no
wait a while yep
sisters have taken quite a liking to you
especially boggs
i don't suppose it would help any if i
explain to them i'm not homosexual it
would not well if there's any trouble i
won't use the rock hammer they find it
you're gonna lose it they do catch you
with it you don't know me
i understand
i could see why some of the boys took
him for snobby
they had a quiet way about him there's
such a good cat mystery between them i
think it would be fair to say
i liked andy from the start
red
[Music]
red's the kind of guy you could be
friends with outside of prison too right
running low
ah [ __ ]
yep there it is
i wish i could tell you that andy fought
the good fight but prison is no
fairytale world
he never said who did it
but we all knew yeah that's horrible i
do believe those first two years were
the worst for
two years it was outdoor
detail and may is one damn fine month to
be working outdoors ellis reading
wouldn't you know it
me and some fellas i know were among the
names
called 35 000 that's what he left me
poor barons
terrible [ __ ] luck huh crying shame
some people really got it awful
step aside mert this fucker's having
himself an accident you don't push him
off the roof because if you do trust it
there's no reason you can't keep that 35
000.
35 000. all of it all of it every penny
you better start making sense
give it to your wife the irs allows a
one-time only gift to your spouse for up
to sixty thousand dollars oh [ __ ]
tax-free tax-free irs can't touch one
cent
yeah that smart banker would kill his
wife aren't you why should i believe a
smart banker like you cause he's a smart
banker
if you get the forms i'll prepare them
for you
nearly free of charge
i'd only ask three beers a piece for
each of my co-workers
i think a man working outdoors feels
more like a man if you can have a bottle
of suds
okay
and that's how it came to pass not bad
as for andy
he spent that break hungered in the
shade
a strange little smile on his face
watching us drink his beer
want a cold one andy
no thanks
gave up drinking
you're a nice guy
what do you want
rita hayworth what
so this is johnny farrell i've heard a
lot about you johnny
really take a few weeks weeks
well yeah andy i don't have a stuff down
in front of my pants right now i'm sorry
to say
[Laughter]
how would you get rita hayward
and to spend a month in the infirmary
the sisters never laid a finger on andy
again and boggs never walked again well
okay i'm thinking andy could use a nice
welcome back when he gets out of the
infirmary man likes to place chess
let's get him some rocks
[Music]
i love this reaction
[Music]
oh
heads up
toss and sells
oh no
a real messed up way of inspecting [ __ ]
pleased to see you reading this
any favorite passages watch ye therefore
for you know not when the master of the
house coming
hey jake where's brooks
tandy and i i thought i heard you out
here
i've been reassigned to you
i know they told me
ain't that a kick in the head ain't that
a kick in the head
i'm deacons
i was uh
thinking about maybe setting up some
kind of trust fund for my kids
educations
ah
mr
deakins and then andy says it mr deacon
you want your sons to go to harvard or
yay
bars are concerned only three ways to
spend the taxpayers hard-earned when it
comes to prisons
more walls more bars more guards still i
i'd like to try with your permission
i'll write a letter a week they can't
ignore me forever sure can
i'll even mail them for you how's that
will you mail them
the following april andy did tax returns
for half the guards of shawshank oh my
god
year after that he did them all
including the wardens
year after that they rescheduled the
start of the intramural season to
coincide with taxis
oh my goodness
yes sir and it was a regular cottage
industry
in fact it got so busy at tax time
he was allowed to staff oh cool so put
the knife down
brooks brooks look at me put the knife
down hmm
brooks huh look at his neck for god's
sake
it's the only way they'd let me stay
come on this is crazy
what what the hell did you do to send
him off anyway i didn't do nothing i
come in here to say fairly well
ain't you heard his parole come through
i just don't understand what happened in
there that's fine
oh man this is his home you can never
get like that oh yeah
say that when you've been here as long
as brookson's
goddamn right
they send you here for life
that's exactly what they take
part it counts anyway
that is crazy
i wonder how
if that happens often to people i can't
take care of you no more jake
you go on now
you're free oh
wow
[Music]
god 50 years man
i can't believe how fast things move on
the outside
[Music]
i saw an automobile once when i was a
kid but i was just thinking about that
just thinking about that the parole
board got me into this halfway house
called the brewer
and a job
it's hard work i try to keep up but my
hands hurt most of the time
oh
sometimes after work i go to the park
and feed the birds
i keep thinking
jake might just show up and
say hello
but he never does
oh poor guy
i have bad dreams like i'm falling
i wake up scared
sometimes it takes me a while to
remember where i am
it's so fascinating maybe i should get
me a gun and rob the food way so they'd
send me home
i've decided
not to stay
i doubt they'll kick up any fuss
not for an old
crook like me
[Music]
oh holy [ __ ]
[Music]
yes tell hey what i'm
sorry i put a knife to his throat
a hard feeling
damn
that was such an unexpected part of this
movie to me
what's all this you tell me [ __ ] stick
they're all addressed to you
huh
what this is 200
in addition the library district has
generously responded with a charitable
donation of used books and sundries
we trust this will fill your needs
we now consider the matter closed please
stop sending us a letter
[Laughter]
it only took six years from now on i'll
write two letters a week instead of one
[Music]
andy do you hear that
[Music]
is that italian music
[Music]
don't be too bold man okay you're going
bold
[Music]
you will now be competing in this year's
hunger games it was like some beautiful
bird flapped into our trap little cage
and made those walls dissolve away
and for the briefest of moments
every last man at shawshank felt free
that's why he did it
for that feeling
[Music]
i am warning you dufresne turn that off
[Music]
[Applause]
oh great and it got two weeks in the
hole for that little stunt
on your feet
and you you couldn't play something good
huh and hank williams
they broke the door down before i could
take requests
[Laughter]
that's the beauty of music they
can't get that from you
haven't you ever felt that way about
music
i play the main monica as a younger man
yeah
lost interest in it though
didn't make much sense in here
here's where it makes the most sense
you need it so you don't forget come on
ready get a harmonica
hope it's a dangerous thing
hope to drive a man insane
he's got no use on the inside oh i
better get used to that idea i hope you
get out of here by the end red
you feel you've been rehabilitated
oh yes
and i can honestly say i'm a changed man
no danger to society here
god's honest truth
and the hope debate lives on
here
little parole rejection present
go ahead and open it
i had to go through one of your
competitors i hope you don't mind i
wanted to be a surprise
he got the harmonica
thank you
you're gonna play it
oh
not right now
when you get out
guys such a long time
i know rita hayworth who the hell is
that
and you'd be amazed how far andy could
stretch it
he made deals with book clubs charity
groups he bought remainder books by the
pound count monte crisco that's christo
you dumb [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the rest of us did our best to pitch in
when and where we could
by the year kennedy was shot
and they had transformed the storage
room smelling of rat turds and
turpentine
into the best prison library in new
england wow
address this
thank you sir
have this shitty pie problem with having
all that money the sonar lady you're
gonna have to explain where it came from
well that's where i come in i send that
money out into the real world
and when it comes back cleaners of
virgins honey potter the time norton
retires i'll have made him a millionaire
now you're a real criminal
i know you're good at it but all that
paper leaves a trail fbi irs whatever
it's gonna lead to somebody i'm sure it
is but not to me
certainly not to the warden
randall stephen who second cousin to
harvey the rabbit
he doesn't exist
except on paper you can't just make a
person up mr stevens has a birth
certificate driver's license social
security number
you're [ __ ] me i had to come to
prison to be a crook
i got the tv like this it's a big old
thing i couldn't see [ __ ] freeze kid
hands in the air you hear what i said
boy
i say yes sir i sure did but if i
dropped this [ __ ] thing you got me on
destruction of property too
you don't seem to be a very good thief
maybe you should try something else
yeah well what the hell you know about
it capone
what are you in for
me
lawyer [ __ ] me
everybody's innocent in here
don't you know that
tim province is so good in this feel bad
let him down
oh that's crap kid
he's proud of you
what's he in here for anyway
murder
the hell you say
caught his wife in bed with some golf
bro we used them both
four years ago
i was in thomas and on a two to three
stretch
oh my god no way
about six months left to go
get a new cell mate in
elmo blatch
big twitchy [ __ ] oh my god he knows who
did it so i pick out this guy
gives me [ __ ]
so he killed him him in this tasty [ __ ]
he was with
she's [ __ ] this prixy this
golf pro but she's very some other guy
oh my god some hot shot banker oh my god
and he's the one they painted on jesus
that's everything right there
i have to say that's the most amazing
story i ever heard sir
oh they would want to keep him here
the country club will have his old time
cards
records w-2s with his name on it frane
if you want to indulge this fantasy
that's your business don't make it mine
this meeting is over oh
get in here now she's trying to set your
mind at ease that's all sir
cemetery a month oh my god
the kid passed c plus average oh
wow
just made the cut
jordan wants to talk
no no this does not look like good news
i have to know if what you told dufresne
was the truth yes sir
absolutely would you be willing to swear
before a judge and jury
having placed your hand on the good book
just give me that chance why does this
feel like a mislead
that's what i thought
god damn it i'm sure by now you've heard
a terrible thing less than a year ago
trying to escape
broke kept natalie's heart to shoot him
we just have to put it behind us
oh my god i hope you get [ __ ] the
electric chair man you will do the
hardest time there is
no more protection from the guards
catching my drift
or am i being obtuse
give him another month to think about it
another month i didn't pull the trigger
i drove her away
and that's why she died because of me
oh no
feel bad about it if you want to but you
didn't pull the trigger no i didn't
i think he'll ever get out of here one
day when i got a long white beard and
two or three marbles rolling around
upstairs they let me out
he'll become god
i guess it comes down to a simple choice
really
you're busy living
you'll get busy die
god the acting in this is so
good
he asked me for a lengthy rope
bro
six feet long
and you gave it to me
sure i did why wouldn't i
remember brooks hamlin no
and he'd never do that every man has his
breaking point look at me split want to
get home
come on figure it out my stuff down the
laundry
and shine my shoes
i want them looking like mirrors good
having you back andy
place wasn't the same without you
it's completely stripping of everything
[Music]
he gets his most hopeful opportunity
and then that's when
all hope becomes lost man missing on
tier two cell 245.
do fray
get your ass out here boy you hold up
the show
don't make me come down there i'll thump
your skull for you
maybe he broke out
[Music]
[Laughter]
tell me what this is last night's
account mm-hmm i sure do see right there
dufresne i want him found
not tomorrow not after breakfast now
how to get out did he use that shovel
thingy this is a conspiracy
damn conspiracy and everyone's in on it
no no
[Music]
in 1966
andy dufresne
escaped from shawshank prison
please tell me he got all they found of
him was a muddy set of prison clothes a
bar of soap
and an old rock hammer there it is
that's when he had the idea
turns out and his favorite hobby was
toting his wall out into the exercise
yard
a handful at a time
and he decided he'd been here just about
long enough look at this good i want to
get home
oh please tell me there's [ __ ] in there
to convict him
three deposits tonight
yes he took it
andy crawl to freedom through 500 yards
of [ __ ] smelling foulness i can't even
imagine
or maybe i just don't want to
[Music]
some goddamn determination that's the
length of five football fields oh my god
[Music]
you clever son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
please tell me he gets away
please
a man nobody ever laid eyes on before
strolled into the main national bank
until that moment
he didn't exist
except on paper did he know my god
driver's license price certificate
social security card
and the signature was a spot on yeah
i hope you'll enjoy living abroad
it's so good
i love this
will there be anything else
please
could you add this to your outgoing mail
i'd be happy to
oh
good
this is so cathartic
all told he blew town with better than
370
000 of warden norton's money wow
good morning portland daily bubble
oh man
[Music]
this is the greatest finale in all of
movie history right here i wasn't there
to see it but i hear byron hadley
started sobbing like a little girl when
they took him away
a little [ __ ] norton had no intention
of going that quietly
[Music]
oh no make it easy on yourself
man
nah he deserved to rot in prison i got a
postcard in the mail when i picture him
heading south in his own car with a top
down
it always makes me laugh
i have to remind myself that some birds
aren't meant to be caged does red get
out no
i guess i just miss my friend
please for the love of christ let her go
if i'll say you've served 40 years of a
life sentence feel you've been
rehabilitated it's just a [ __ ] word
so you go on and stamp your form sonny
and stop wasting my time
oh
yeah
he did it
did he get to say goodbye to his friends
yeah they just put them up in the same
ass place
oh man find that oak tree if andy
already didn't go to it there's a harsh
truth to face
no way i'm gonna make it on the outside
don't say that man please for the love
of god toad
all i do anymore is think of ways to
break my parole only one thing stops me
a promise i made to andy
like a
tree that god would send messages
through
that rock that rock definitely doesn't
look like it belongs to the other rocks
he went back there and left a letter for
him didn't he
he did
if you're reading this you've gotten out
and if you've come this far maybe you're
willing to come a little further
you remember the name of the town don't
you say about the name yeah it's good
every day remember red
hope is a good thing
maybe the best of things that is so
beautiful
i'm guilty of committing a crime
a role violation
of course i doubt they'll toss up any
roadblocks for that board and got texas
please
i'm so happy right now
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh that was so beautiful
that was very touching
that was extremely touching i wish we
got to see him say bye to his friends in
prison though red
release the extended
is there a post-credits scene of red's
friends sitting around just going
anyone's seen red lately
haven't seen red around here oh
beautiful
that was beautiful
okay
wow
what a journey
what a journey
where to begin
[Music]
it's really an ultimate bromance movie
isn't it
do people say that about this film do
people say this is a bromance i really
didn't know anything about it uh i i i
knew it took place in a prison that's
all i've ever really known about it and
of course seeing the poster
for it
i didn't realize that's what the poster
was gonna be representing ultimately in
the end and uh i was very satisfied with
it
you know like from just the
the takeaway of like the main technical
things that i imagine people always mean
not all this technical uh however you
know you
thinking about like
the performances are just phenomenal
like morgan freeman
is
excellent just so natural
and it's interesting because you usually
see nowadays you see him kind of play
like
i mean he does a lot of he does a lot of
types of work now but you don't really
get to see him do rules like this
anymore
i mean maybe he does and i'm just out of
the loop but in terms of like the
prominent films or the bigger films he
tends to be a part of the rules like
this not so much
and so to get it to see him do this role
is so
real so natural
and and same thing with tim robbins just
excellent in this film
uh
very internal performance
subdued
and
i i think the way they often times when
you do stories that span a lot of time
like they spend a lot of time here
and oftentimes you do stories like this
it can feel you can feel like it's it's
going a little too like imagine like a
typical biopic where you complain about
you know the way they span time just
imagine those complaints applied to here
and i would not apply that here
yet i think that's part of the
uniqueness of it is you can feel kind of
the wear and tear it does on the soul
of these characters but it's never done
in a way that feels forceful
it all feels so natural
because you know you start this movie
out with you know red getting rejected
once again to get out of shawshank
and he doesn't seem as
resistant towards the possibility of him
getting out and then as the movie
progresses you know any time the talk of
dreams or escaping or being let go from
here
that it
you could see that there's such pushback
there's such a defense mechanism that
comes up
in the conversation and that the thought
of that is a threat the thought of that
is a fear to to it's like painful to
think about because
it will never come true
that's or or if it does come true
terror awaits because now it's been so
conditioned and this is home now this is
most of
most of the individual life is spent
here that the outside world is
uncomfortable and you don't belong
you know like a lot of these people who
who wind up here end up finding a
different place of belonging in a
different place of purpose
so i like like the details and i think
that's one of the things about this
movie is
it's the details it's really easy to
look at a film like this i imagine
especially after with 94. god so many
movies damn good movies came out there
um i don't know if this film won any
awards i i actually i'm way out of the
loop on this i believe it lost the
forest gump that's what i believe is
that
the
right anywho
it's easy to look at a film like this
and go uh yeah melodramatic a little bit
predictable
i mean
predictable in terms of where the plots
might end up but
it's about the details of the experience
it's about getting lost in it because i
actually thought this movie was more
immersive
than i was expecting it to be like
i don't often depends on you know
exactly what kind of film you're
watching and i wasn't expecting to
get as swept up in it or as immersed in
it and weirdly i actually think a lot of
that credit goes to
morgan freeman's narration
a classic morgan freeman narration is
this when it started the classic morgan
freeman narration
because
you know often
out in l.a you meet a lot of people who
are screenwriters and you hear uh you
know people constantly debate like
narration is a weak man's storytelling
motif like don't do it and i actually
thought it was used quite effectively
and i thought it actually helped enhance
the immersiveness of the film
because you are weaving in and out of
two perspectives throughout this film
you're weaving it out of red's
perspective and you're weaving into
andy's perspective
and
there's the juxtaposition there's the
clash
of
andy who is trying obviously as stated
in the film is trying to hold on to hope
maintain some level of optimism
and then you have red
who as time goes on is losing more and
more of that hope and the fear is
becoming the
by the way just gotta say this really
fast the brooks character
very effective stuff i love that they
allowed the film
to break away from the main two
narratives of red and andy and just
spend time like a little short film
within this massive film
to spend time with brooks on the outside
world
and really show that feeling of being
living in this isolated place
and
you know going from a place where you
you found family you found friends you
you found order you know in some weird
way
and you found purpose like he
all of us i imagine
imagine all of us
long for a sense of belonging and a
sense of feeling like we have some type
of purpose
um whether that be on a major level or a
minor level
you know and
anything that helps us feel like we
belong and usually that's associated
with like what's my purpose in here
and it's so easy to define that where
it's kind of like you're starting all
over again it's easy to get kind of lost
in the masses and also you know you're
when you're there for so long you're out
of touch with the way times have changed
you haven't changed with the times
because you weren't around to experience
the societal changes
and they really captured that so
so eloquently perfect with the brooks
character that it was heartbreaking like
that to me was uh one of the most
heartbreaking parts of this whole story
was seeing how that happens that's the
fear that every man eventually has when
i like that really opened my eyes to
you know like there's there's constantly
a lot of
talks um you know circular that i'm not
as well versed in as i ought to be or i
haven't taken the time to dive into
incarceration treatment
and just how messed up it is
you know because like i only ever truly
hear about like the terrible people when
i watch like true crime documentaries or
something like that or a true crime docu
series
and like yeah lock them away for good
but the the mistreatment of people who
are like nah they shouldn't be
incarcerated for that long you know and
that's movie kind of shows that and it
also shows
the kind of
negative effect it can have because you
imagine that you're in prison oh my god
you've been there for so long you must
just want to get out but then i never
thought about
that
feeling it's like it's not exactly
stockholm syndrome but i imagine in some
ways it can kind of feel
it's just
it's habitual it's like this is your
habitat now you know
and
and and i think the way they painted
that with the brook storyline was really
powerful
and so then you have here the
juxtaposition between the two main
characters you know which path is it
gonna go down for them which belief
system will ultimately fall under
because the story's so much about
resilience and perseverance in the face
of
obstacles where everything just seems
like
andy was sexually assaulted physically
beaten
tortured abused on all the counts
stripped of everything
and he never gave up and he was always
and i think there's there is a certain
level what i thought was cool
about the way it's about this
how it's woven is this sort of woven
like i would use the words woven like a
tail because
um t-a-l-e for clarity on that
because
red is so much about think realistic
and andy's journey is a bit of this
cathartic
fantasy fulfillment of the man wronged
who
managed to inspire and influence
these people and and and have them be
educated and do
good deeds and look and grow bigger
hearts grow some love and expand their
love expand their vocabulary
and then
manage to use his imagination to break
out of there put the warden behind and
get the warden caught
on his corruption like
so he's living he's he's bringing the
fantasy to life you know because i
imagine that for this character he is
fantasizing about the outcome that he
ultimately does get not just being able
to be in mexico and be on the beach and
it's it's all the other things that
happen along the way the details
and bringing that to reality and i think
stories like this are so timeless
because
even if you're not i've never been
incarcerated or been close to
and most of us haven't and i i feel like
though that there's so much here that is
relatable in our own ways you know
because i this character with an home
kind of hopping all over the place here
it's a it's a long movie and it's three
in the morning right now um
like with the andy character
because he is so downtrodden and it's
not a story of like i was wrong i need
to get out of here it's he accepts his
prison sentence pretty early on
as a like this punishment
as if he is deserving of it and as the
movie reveals that he he ultimately did
feel like even though he's not the one
who pulled the trigger that he did feel
responsible for
his wife's death
and
that guilt
is the thing that has allowed him to
accept this condemnation and try to make
the most of it and then try to do some
good while he's in there too
i forgot where i was going with the
point but i was just getting kind of
lost in that because oh yes that is a
very relatable point that's a very
relatable thing in its own way of you
know a lot of us often
can fall
into the feelings of guilt or shame in
ways that are not actually our faults
but we accept them as our faults and
punish ourselves
and you do got to get to a point of
climbing out of that hole you literally
there's like it's such a good metaphor
of like
climbing out of this hole now the time
has come
to
feel be free of it all again like he's
accepted his sentence he hasn't even
fought to get out
he's he didn't put up a fight this whole
time he was there he just accepted it
and now he gets to climb out of that
hole
and i think the other main relatable
part of it of what i imagine has made
this movie just develop in popularity
over time and has been so timeless is
the fact that
that
that thought process of
thinking realistic
i know he's not the most popular person
to quote right now but will smith would
often talk about this
is think like
not
the feelings of thinking realistic and
the feelings of being a dreamer you know
being someone who
can hold on to a fantasy and try to make
that fantasy become the reality because
when you think realistic that's so
limiting and you just pigeonhole
yourself into
having not such a fulfilling life
and i i think you know
painting a story like that's the basis
of the the narrative and the themes of
don't get caught up and thinking
realistic learn to be hopeful learn to
be
be a dreamer think bigger
you know it's but it's in the story of
prison sentence and
and then ultimately in the finale of a
prison
of a breaking out of prison
so i think having rooted in those themes
of despite all things that are piling on
against you despite all odds all the
obstacles
you don't
don't
forget to hold on to that hope that's
why that
scene with the music is so beautiful
uh where he plays the replays that with
that inspiration that feeling of
escapism
and that escapism doesn't have to be
just a form of
you know
stepping away from reality like yes but
there's a beauty to that that's why we
like watching [ __ ] movies man that's
why we like watching shows it is an
escapism it totally is
but
if you can run away with some sense of
inspiration that you can actually apply
then beautiful things can come from that
you know and you know when you hear
people that say movies change my life i
always kind of wonder like to what
degree has it changed your life is it
just the feeling that it gave you or did
you actually like do something with that
feeling or the thought process that
sparked and yeah then something really
did change for you
and i can imagine that this movie can
have that effect for people that
either grew up with it or found it
pretty early on in life or maybe they
found it late in life and then they
they were able to
uh hold on to any of that inspiration
that
stayed in their brain and their heart
and then rolled with it
so there's so much beauty here and i i
don't know i guess i was expecting to
walk into like a dark-ass drama because
i heard prison movie and it's r-rated
and yeah i mean it definitely feels
r-rated and i heard you know stephen
king wrote it so i do i wasn't expecting
a movie that
leaned more into the those
optimistic qualities
and i appreciated that so much
and i think frank darabont did it did an
excellent job because so much about this
movie
to beyond just capturing the span of
time working with his editor oh the
music by thomas oh phenomenal too that
is that's great music
like
you know it's like i'm so used to roger
deacon's cinematography as of now which
is [ __ ] like prisoners and blade runners
like striking dark moody ass [ __ ]
i forgot this was roger deakins
but i think they captured the
the personality of the prisons so well
beyond just its cast of characters
the architecture of it all there
there was a there is a sense of of
history and who these people evolved
into
and and i like that it didn't just hone
in on things that i would normally
expect which is people just kind of
going crazy
like it's going stir crazy
it leaned more into
uh finding
light and darkness which was something i
wasn't expecting
it's in some ways if you just cut out a
few things or change some dialogue and
and switch around some scenes
it could have been a pg-13 movie but it
wouldn't have been as good of a movie it
wouldn't have been as effective you need
some of the harsher [ __ ] in here in
order for a lot of these other things to
hit home much stronger in the fields
so yeah i mean i thought it was a
beautiful film i thought it was really
strong
and
i'm glad i've watched it it's such a
random move for me to watch i've been
watching so many things um
in my you know some things on camera
here a lot of more emotional [ __ ]
there's so much more like things where
i'm like damn i've been watching a lot
of emotional stuff lately uh but even
off camera you know i've been watching
like a lot more things that are about
like
love and doing doing kinder things doing
good things
and uh being more optimistic in life
about
a lot of what i watch and i'm also
catching up on westworld i'm only on
season two
so there's there's that which is not the
feelings i'm talking about
but then you know i'm also watching like
love on the spectrum a great netflix
reality show which i i highly recommend
and um
yeah
yeah uh this this movie
was impactful in a way i wasn't
expecting you know i met i i thought it
would just be this downtrodden dark
depressing hole of the film and then
eventually it would become this very
touching moving inspirational drama but
it was kind of kind of the vibe
throughout and i and and i wasn't
expecting that
and uh and i'm glad it'd be filled with
that it was it was awesome
tim robbins is excellent morgan
freeman's good the wrestling william
sadler is a wonderful presence
the warden [ __ ] i forget that actor's
name
but he's very effective here uh clancy
brown always an effective [ __ ]
it's funny how clancy brown
forgot how creepy crap clancy brown
looked when he was younger because
clancy brown today you know i've uh
what is like a modern touchdown is it
the main betty and uh i don't know if
you guys watched it but the revival of
the the real final season of dexter
and that's that's the clancy brown that
comes to mind for me now just like a
heavier set guy with white hair and a
beard like that's that's classic brown i
know or someone who's like a lot of
makeup or does a lot of voice over work
he's got his voice has become more
definitive over time and i forgot how
creepy this guy was
he's a little creepy looking he seems
nicer now like when he plays like a
nicer party i actually believe him but
damn i forgot how creepy he was but the
but the costume design on this film was
also excellent too
everything about this i i love the art
direction of it very much so
so yeah
fascinating to learn more facts about it
but really touching stuff and a great
great messages and
i i love the ending of it as well
yeah i i wasn't expecting it to be like
damn this finale is cool this is a cool
finale
and that wasn't the vibe but i think it
earned it so much and i love how they
like planted all the seeds for
every little every little bit of that
escape plan and i like how it just it it
went through like he escaped and he did
it it wasn't
you know being chased by dogs in the
middle of the night streets and i get
over there to get them you know
like crazy elaborate plan walked off
with a lot of money use the phantom to
be able to
to get some documents out there got the
the warden caught i thought it was great
it was excellent excellent films oh yeah
shout out to my friend andrew gordon i
have any friend
in real life who has been insistent on
me watching this i think he declares
this as his favorite movie out of any
friend who's been insistent on me
watching it it's been andrew gordon and
many of you guys suggested it after
forrest gump and uh i'm glad i did this
was uh this was a nice experience
so thank you guys very much subscribe
leave a like
and we'll catch you all
catch you all soon thank you
[Music]
you